women say I'm traditional in a sense it
means I want to be courted I want to
know I want to this is what they mean I
want to be courted like a traditional
woman even though I'm not one because
I'm not a virgin I'm not married before
25 I don't have a cookbook oh but I cook
one to two times a week so yeah I'm
traditional now I'm like if you I swear
to God if you had a conversation with
the actual real traditional women oh my
God and I I I've been talking to them
for this wife's school oh my God they
run circles around us they make all
their meals from scratch from scraps
they've been raising kids and in a kid's
like situations where they're in charge
of children since they're like 16.
they've been either babysitting this
woman had 10 foster kids wow that's
that's a real traditional woman she's
growing at her garden in the backyard